[Musique]
la commune de bras-panon signe son pacte
de solidarité territoriale
un dispositif dead et d'accompagnement
en faveur des communes
initié par le département de la réunion
bras-panon dispose d'une enveloppe
budgétaire de 2 4 millions d'euros dead
en investissement et de 600000 euros
dédiés au fonctionnement
on va surtout aller sur l'accompagnement
portage de repas à domicile nous allons
pour continuer à en faire un peu plus
nous faisons sans portage de repas à
domicile surferont 200 portage de repas
à domicile
pareil le ce fonctionnement permettra de
financer la la sécurité des personnes
âgées dans le cadre d'un partenariat
avec des opérateurs qui aujourd'hui sont
sur la télésurveillance de personnages
et nous prendrons en charge avec le
département 50 % de la valeur du service
dont ces personnes âgées en ont besoin
les élèves de l'école primaire ma pensée
à bras panon dispose d'outils numériques
pour suivre les enseignements un
établissement connectés qui grâce au
pacte de solidarité territoriale ouvrira
deux classes inclusive
une vingtaine d'enfants autistes ou avec
des troubles du comportement pourront
intégrer ces unités d'enseignement donc
ce sont des classes qui vont être
équipés adapter une oeuvre qui vont être
livrés pour la fin au même pas fan cette
année début de l'année prochaine et qui
a une valeur de 300 millions
salazie signe également son pacte de
solidarité territoriale avec le
département une commune d eau qui se
voit attribuer une aide de 2 millions
400 mille euros pour son développement
et son désenclavement
nous sommes à l'ère du numérique tout va
très très vite maintenant il est
important que les enfants de nos écoles
soit équipés de tablettes et que nous
puissions avec nos enfants travailler
sur cette ère du numérique qu'ils
puissent avoir ainsi dans le
désenclavement lesur et salazie est un
endroit enclavé est important que nous
puissions avoir un désenclavement de
siège de soleil
mais c'est aussi d'autres projets sur
l'eau potable c'est des projets sur
l'amélioration des routes et des chemins
de salazie tout ça pour gagner de la
population pour son développement
le pacte de solidarité territoriale
prévoit une enveloppe globale de 90
millions d'euros disponibles sur trois
ans un dispositif que le département
souhaite rapidement étendre à l'ensemble
des communes de l'île il ya une forme
d'urgence sociale les mesures sociales
doivent être mobilisés rapidement
nous voulons renforcer le lien social
nous voulons renforcer aussi les mesures
en termes d'équipements de proximité
c'est pour cela que je ne veux pas tant
des jeux passe commune après commune
je rencontre les maires les équipes
municipales pour aller signer et
mobiliser les crédits
moi j'ai envie qu'on aille vite parce
que la population de l'exigent
il y a des attentes faute et ces
attentes doivent être bien sûr
satisfaites
à travers ces packs de solidarité
[Musique]